many things in our lives  are temporary  sometimes very temporary yet i see so  many people treating it as it's forever  so i just wanted to say one thing about  that this morning a little morning hello  to everybody hope you have a really nice  day i hope everyone's good and this uh  most things in life are temporary thing  if that's true which i think most people  agree it is  what that actually means is please  consider leaning deep into gratitude  when it's good when you're happy about  something when you're enjoying it  and please  deploy patience  and perspective what's a struggle  today's a bad day  tomorrow has such a huge opportunity to  be the beginning  keep that in mind  whatever the energy is for you today  understand that there's always tomorrow